- It's my pleasure to introduce
Dr. Sarah Walker here today.
Dr. Walker is a senior lecturer
at the School of Economics
at the University of New South
Wales in Sydney, Australia.
We're really delighted that
she has agreed to get up early
so she can have part of
her day overlap with ours
and present in our seminar this afternoon.
Sarah is a really very
talented emerging scholar
in the fields of development economics,
environmental economics, economic history.
Sort of her work centers on
a lot of really interesting
questions related to
institutions, culture,
and also sort of
development the environment.
Sarah's work has won sort of
several honors and awards.
So in 2020, the Paul Burke
Award for early career research
from the Academy of Social
Sciences in Australia.
She's also a winner
of the Discovery Early
Career Research Award
from the Australian Research Council.
And today she's going to
be sharing some of her
really fascinating work
with us that she's done
on refugee communities in Kenya.
I will pass it over to Sarah for her talk.
She is allowed interruptions throughout
sort of in the econ style talk.
So if you have any questions,
please raise your hand
or use the chat feature.
If you use the chat feature, I
will sort of find a nice time
to interject and ask the questions.
That way she doesn't have
to monitor the chat herself.
So without further ado,
I'll pass it over to Sarah
for the talk.
- Great. Thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Emily.
Thank you so much to the
center for inviting me.
This is a real pleasure,
and I'm excited to share
this work with you.
This is actually kind of an
older project at this point.
This is first of all joint
work with Jennifer Alix-Garcia,
who is an economist at
Oregon State University,
and incidentally is also
the former PhD advisor
to myself and to Emily.
So we share a very common bond there.
And it's also joint
work with Anne Bartlett,
who's a sociologist at
University of New South Wales
here in Sydney.
So it's truly an
interdisciplinary set of work,
and I'm delighted to share this
with an interdisciplinary audience.
So we actually collected the
data for this project in 2015,
and I'm going to present today
to you two papers actually
that have already been published.
So one in 2018 and one in 2019,
which is a little bit awkward, I must say,
for an economist because we're
really used to presenting
work in progress and sort
of getting feedback there.
But nonetheless, I think
it's important work
and I hope you do as well,
and I'm still interested
obviously in your comments
and having a discussion around this.
So thanks for that.
So the motivation for
this work is, obviously,
it's no secret to the people
in this room that the numbers
of forcibly displaced people
are at an all-time high.
So when you look at the
most recent data coming out
from UNHCR in 2022, this
stands at 103 million
displaced people, currently
32.5 million of whom
are refugees.
And actually, as I was
preparing for this seminar,
I went back to these slides
that I made a few years ago
when it was still a work in progress.
And at that time, the
data from UNHCR in 2016
was 65 million displaced people
and about 22.5 million refugees.
So you can see even in these six years,
the numbers have skyrocketed
and they're only going
to continue to rise as
people flee affected regions
and seek asylum internationally.
Something that I think we
also know about this situation
with refugees is that
many refugees are living
in permanent settlements.
So they're living in camps.
The best data that I could
come across is still from 2015,
when we were collecting our data.
So about 41% of refugees
live in camps that have been
in place for over five years.
These are long-term protracted situations,
and there are seven settlements
worldwide with populations
over 80,000 people.
So these are like cities,
these are small cities,
sometimes large cities,
depending on which camp you're looking at.
So these camps are...
The largest camp is in Bangladesh
with over 700,000 refugees living there.
We're going to look at a camp in Kenya.
Kenya has a couple of very large camps
with populations over 180,000 people.
Other places include
Jordan, Uganda, and Sudan.
So one of the main features
of the refugee situation
that I like to highlight
is that most refugees,
83% of refugees are actually living
in low or middle-income countries.
And in high-income countries
like the US or Australia,
where I'm living, or especially in Europe,
a lot of the debate in
policy is coming around,
is focused on, "Well,
how is this impacting us
and high-income countries?"
But one thing I like to
highlight is that the majority
of refugees are living in low
and middle-income countries
that already are not in the best position
to host refugees financially,
but nonetheless they do.
The other statistic I'd like to highlight
is that a large percentage,
69% of refugees,
come from just five countries.
So, as we know, there's ongoing
crises in Syria, Venezuela,
Afghanistan, South Sudan,
Myanmar, which is only increasing.
We are going to focus on the camp,
a particular camp in Kenya,
which is largely home
to South Sudanese
refugees who've been there
for now over 30 years.
So the first question we
asked with this project was,
how do refugee camps
impact host communities?
There's a large debate around
hosting displaced people.
It's a very heated debate.
But especially at the time
we were conducting this work,
the empirical evidence was very sparse.
I think in recent years there's
been a large contribution
to the literature, and I
think people in the room
probably know more about the
more recent work than I do,
and I'd love to hear what you have to say.
But it's kind of an empirical question,
how do refugee camps
impact host communities?
And this is really important
for policymaking because,
especially at the time we were
conducting our field work,
the Kenya government was on the verge
of shutting down camps.
And it was important to
understand what are the impacts
of these camps before
we throw the baby out
with the bathwater?
Some of these concerns are not misplaced.
There's fear of labor market competition,
but there's also potential
benefits from hosting refugees,
including stimulating demand,
filling labor market gaps,
innovation, and exchange of knowledge.
So we explore a specific
case of long-run encampment
in a place called Kakuma, Kenya,
which is in the northwestern
region of Kenya,
on the border of South Sudan.
And this camp has been
in existence since 1992.
And we will explore...
Not only we'll look at
sort of the average of economic impacts,
so that's also important to highlight.
There's a lot of other impacts
that are relevant for policy.
But as primarily an economist,
what we're studying here
are the economic impacts,
and then we want to
explore relevant channels,
if we do find any impacts.
The second question we asked was,
well, how are refugees surviving?
So largely in most refugee
camps, countries are practicing
a policy of what they call enclosure.
So refugees can't really leave the camp,
they can't work outside of the camps,
which means they have to live
off predominantly of food aid
or internal camp economy.
So one of the things I'll
show you today is that there's
a flourishing economy
within the camp itself.
And/or they live off of
remittances from relatives
who are either living in
the country that was fled
or living elsewhere in the world,
maybe in higher-income countries.
And so what happened, this second question
sort of just landed in
our laps by happenstance.
So when we were in the camp in 2015,
collecting the data
for the first question,
there was a sort of what we'd
call a natural experiment
that occurred where one
channel of remittances
was completely cut off and
we were able to measure
what happens when this
channel is shut down.
So you can imagine that
obviously there would be impacts
on refugee households that
use this form of remittances,
but also if there are
inter-linkages economically
between the host and
the refugee community,
there could also be
externalities or flow-on effects
to the host community.
And so we'll look at that also.
So the context of our
study takes place in Kenya,
which obviously shares a border
with some highly-impacted
refugee sending regions
such as South Sudan,
Somalia, and Ethiopia.
And we are focusing, I'm not
sure if you can see my cursor,
but in the very northwest corner of Kenya,
on the border of South Sudan
is a region called Turkana.
And we're looking specifically at a camp,
basically right about
there, called Kakuma.
So something to know about
Turkana is that it's home
to the Turkana people.
And the Turkana people are
a group of semi-nomadic
pastoralists who are largely disengaged
with a formal economy, and
certainly in the early nineties
were disengaged with a formal economy.
And they mostly herd cattle for a living.
So they'll set up
semi-permanent residences
where they practice maybe a
little bit of horticulture.
Mostly women are practicing
a little bit of horticulture,
and the men predominantly
are herding cattle.
They'll go out for long periods of time
to graze their cattle,
and they'll come back
and then maybe they pick up
and move to another settlement.
Something to note about Turkana
is that it is extremely poor
and isolated.
So this data comes from the 2005 census,
and that was the most recent data we had
at the time of publication.
I just checked the stats from
the 2018 census the other day,
and not much has changed.
And so something to note
is that even when you...
Kenya is a low and
middle-income country itself,
but when you compare Turkana
to the rest of Kenya,
it's even poorer.
So 94%, I think now it's
around 90% of households
living in Turkana are
below the poverty line.
Household sizes are larger than they are
even in other rural parts of Kenya.
School attendance is extremely low.
That has not changed much
in the past almost 20 years.
And households rely far less on farming
than the rest of Kenyan households.
That's largely because the
area of Turkana is very arid.
It's dry. I showed you the picture.
It has a very scrubby set of
foliage. The soil is not great.
And for one of those reasons,
for some of those reasons,
households largely rely on
cattle-herding for a living.
So you can see the average
number of cattle, goats,
sheep owned by Turkana
households is much larger
than households in other parts of Kenya.
So in the early nineties,
along and protracted conflict
in South Sudan intensified,
and 7,000 South Sudanese,
mostly young boys, walked
from South Sudan across
into Ethiopia temporarily and
over the border into Kenya,
and these boys have been
referred to as the Lost Boys.
And there's a lot that's
been written about them.
If you haven't read the
book "What is the What"
by Dave Eggers, it's a
fantastic story, true story,
of one of these boys who fled South Sudan
and ultimately ended up
in the United States.
But it gives a really intimate
portrayal of what these boys
endured in their journey.
So in 1991, around 7,000
young boys walked into Kenya
and settled actually just over the border
in a town called Lokichogio.
And by the following year, more
and more people had started
to come over the border and
the government of Kenya agreed
to set up a refugee camp
in the town of Kakuma,
which at the time had a
population of less than 6,000.
By the following year,
35,000 people were living in the camp,
and essentially overnight,
Kakuma became a city.
And by 2015, at the time
when we were conducting
our field work, over
180,000 refugees were living
in Kakuma refugee camp, coming
mostly from South Sudan,
but from from other areas
as well, including Somalia,
the DRC, Ethiopia, and Darfur.
And today Kakuma is one
of the longest-standing
refugee camps, and one of
the largest in the world.
So here's an aerial shot of Kakuma.
It is situated between two
rivers that are mostly dry,
but in the rainy seasons
they tend to flood,
and it consists of
semi-permanent structures.
But over time, an economy has developed.
I mean, it's essentially a city now
and there's flourishing markets.
So this is a picture of
one of the central markets
in the camp.
This is Franco's Hotel,
which is a delicious
Ethiopian restaurant where we
would often meet with our team
for lunch and debriefings.
But there's all kinds of markets
and businesses that operate
within the camp, restaurants,
little shops, tailors.
It's really a flourishing economy.
And there's a lot of exchange,
not only among the refugees,
but also among the host population.
So in a lot... So Anne, our
colleague, is a sociologist,
she's a qualitative researcher.
She did a lot of semi-structured
interviews with people.
In a lot of these qualitative interviews,
it became clear that there's
just a very strong link
between the host and the refugee economy.
So many of the Turkana
people use the refugee,
the markets in the camp,
as their main markets.
There's also schools and
hospitals that are accessible
to both the refugee and the
host population within the camp.
- [Emily] Sorry. Sarah, one question.
Are the people in the refugee
camp able to go and work
outside or to work in general?
And if not, I mean,
what means do they use?
I mean, what currency do
they use at that point
in order to get the many, I don't know,
goods and services that have
developed inside this camp?
- Yeah. So thank you for that question.
First, just to answer quickly, no.
So Kakuma practices,
Kenya practices a policy
of full encampment.
So they are not, refugees
are not allowed to work
outside of the camp,
which means that they rely
predominantly on the food aid
that's given to them by UNHCR,
which consists mostly of
flour, oil, beans, and rice,
which they get, depending on
how large their household is,
they get once a month, a set amount.
But something to note is actually that,
and I think this is specific to Kakuma,
I'm sure it's true in other camps,
but I do wanna highlight that the refugees
that are coming into the
camp, relatively speaking,
are wealthier than the Turkana people.
So they're coming with more human capital,
they're also coming with more capital.
And they have links to
people outside of the camp
that send them remittances.
And so that's what
you'll see us talk about
in sort of the second part of the paper.
But in the meantime, if they
can get enough capital to,
for instance, set up a
shop, a lot of refugees
have created their own businesses
and are living off of that
if they can, or remittances,
or in the worst of
circumstances just the food aid
that is given to them.
They can also get employed
by UNHCR as translators
or as teachers or as medical workers,
to the extent that they have the training.
And now, because the camp
has been there for so long,
there's a generation of people,
adults who have grown up,
who were either born in
the camp or moved there
at a very young age and went
to school there and are now
essentially living in the camp
as if it's their hometown.
So when we think about
the possible ways in which
hosting refugees could
affect the local economy,
there are a couple of different...
The predictions are not clear upfront.
So the effects could operate
through many different channels.
The first is a labor market channel.
So one of the, I think the
primary concerns we hear
in higher-income countries
is, "What's gonna happen
when refugees come to our labor markets?
Are these going to depress wages?"
And as long as the locals are
employed in the same market
that refugees are trying to get jobs in,
this could depress wages.
On the other hand, if the
NGOs that are setting up
these refugee camps
demand labor and skills
that the local population has,
this could increase wages
through labor demand.
Another way that refugee
camps could impact
the local economy is through competition
with aid-related goods.
So to the extent that UNHCR
and the WFP are pushing
a whole increased supply
of goods into the market,
if there are producers
locally who are also producing
these goods, that competition,
that's going to depress the price.
First of all, the increase in
supply will depress the price.
If you're a producer,
that's gonna hurt you.
But if you're a consumer,
if you're a net consumer,
that's gonna help you,
'cause now you're paying less
for things that you used to pay more for.
When we think about non-aid goods,
so things that UNHCR and
the WFP are not producing
but maybe are produced locally,
the increase in demand from
the shock in the population
will increase the price.
So that if you're a net
producer of these goods,
that will help you because
you can sell your goods
at a higher price.
But if you're a consumer,
if you're mostly just
consuming these goods,
that increase in the price can hurt you.
So it's not very clear
upfront how hosting refugees
is going to impact the economy.
So we're gonna try and tease
out which of these channels
is happening and look
at the average effects.
So to do this, we combine data
from many, many different data sources.
So the first thing we look at are
so that we can get a nice long-term view.
We take data from nighttime satellites,
which have been pretty
established in the literature
as a good proxy for economic activity.
And even in a place like Turkana,
you can observe nighttime lights.
Even though it is isolated and rural,
you do observe nighttime lights.
At first we were like, "Maybe
we're not gonna see anything,"
but you do.
So we have the GPS data points
for 648 villages in Turkana,
which we then map to the
nighttime lights data in each year
from 1993 to 2013.
And we combine that with data
on the refugee population
in each year.
And so we're going to look essentially
at how far your village is from the camp,
and over time, as the
refugee population increases,
how does the economic activity
in your village fluctuate.
We combine that data also with some data
from the Hunger Safety Net Program,
which was an unconditional
cash transfer program
that was being rolled out
by the government of Kenya
at the time, and it's a
proxy-means tested program.
So they surveyed over 140,000
households to get information
primarily on consumption
to see if they could,
if they were eligible for the program.
And we have access to that
data so we can, at a snapshot,
at least cross-sectionally,
we can understand
consumption of these
households, again, at distances
that are near to the camp
and far from the camp.
We also combine that with
information on livestock prices
over time.
So there's five key
livestock markets in Kenya,
one of which happens to
be located in Turkana.
And we can look at how prices
of livestock fluctuates
in those markets over time as
refugees come in to the camp.
And then finally we collect our own data
from June to July, 2015.
We surveyed around 450 Turkana households,
so in the host population,
and around 170 refugee households.
So again, we have another
snapshot of cross-sectional data,
this time just from within the
camp and then around Turkana.
So we have two empirical
strategies that we will use
to answer this question.
The first is to just look
at the nighttime lights
as a proxy for economic activity.
And we look at whether the
effect of the refugee population
increasing is stronger for
villages closer to the camp,
compared to far away from the camp.
And then we'll corroborate this
with our cross-sectional
data, both from the HSNP,
the cash transfer survey,
again, looking at consumption
close to the camp versus
far away from the camp,
and then also with our own
survey data that we tried
to construct in the best
sort of counterfactual way
that we could, which is
we surveyed households
that were living in Kakuma town,
so something that's important
to notice that host families,
they do not live in the camp,
they live outside of the camp
in Kakuma town and around.
And then we chose two what
we call counterfactual towns
as our control towns.
And the way that we
selected these towns is that
they had to have a similar
population to Kakuma in 1989,
so prior to the arrival of refugees.
And they were situated on
sort of the main artery
that connects Kitale, which is
a town in southwestern Kenya,
to Juba, which is the
capital of South Sudan.
It's a main artery for
the transport of goods,
and obviously is gonna be
important economically.
So we picked towns that were
about the same size as Kakuma
that were situated on this highway,
and then we stratified our random sampling
of these households by their distance
to the center of the town itself.
So here's a map of the Turkana
region, and here is Kakuma,
that's where the refugee camp is located.
Our first counterfactual town
is a town called Lokichogio.
And actually Lokichogio
is also going to be,
we're actually gonna use
it not as a counterfactual
but as a placebo because
Lokichogio is where initially
all of the NGO operations
for the camp were running.
And so we would think
that that's obviously
an important place.
And we can also see if there's
something in particular
about just the NGOs being
there and creating an economy
just through the NGOs.
Or if it's something specific
to actually having refugees,
which is what Kakuma has.
Our two counterfactual towns are Lorugum
which had a similar
population to Kakuma in 1989,
and is situated on this main
artery leading to Uganda,
and Lokichar which again
meets the same criteria
and is situated on this highway.
And interestingly enough, right before,
in the couple of years
before we started collecting
the data, Lokichar had discovered oil
and was all of a sudden sort
of booming economically.
So this is also an interesting
counterfactual place to study
because it obviously
has economic importance,
but it doesn't have refugees.
So I won't bore you too much
with an estimating equation.
Economists would obsess over this,
but just in general, what
we're doing is we're taking
as our dependent variable,
we have an index of nighttime lights.
We take the inverse hyperbolic sine,
which is essentially like a log function
because there is skew in the data.
And we look at as our
independent variables,
we interact the population of
refugees living in the camp
in a particular year,
and we interact that with
how far away your village is.
So we're taking the nighttime lights
in a particular village.
So how far away is your
village from the camp itself.
And then we control for
lots of other things
that vary over time and across space.
So we control for the distance to a road,
which is obviously going
to be very important.
We control for village-fixed
effects and near-fixed effects,
which allow us to capture
unobservable factors
that don't change over time,
so that's the village-fixed effect,
and things that macroeconomic
factors that change over time,
with the year-fixed effects.
And what I'll show you
next is a very messy table,
but I will walk you through it.
In panel A we parametrize
our dependent variable
in a few different ways
just to really check
how robust our estimates are.
And then we also look at
various different constraints
on the data.
So in panel A we're just using
what is the log, essentially,
of the nighttime lights index
as the dependent variable.
And in the first column we look
at our full sample of villages.
In the second column,
we restrict the sample
to only villages that had a
similar population to Kakuma,
so 5,000 people or more in 1989.
And in the third column,
we restrict our villages
to only villages that ever registered
any positive nighttime light
activity ever in history.
And what we can see is that
the further away from the camp
you get, and as the refugee
population increases,
the nighttime lights index goes down.
Or conversely, the closer you get,
the higher the nighttime lights indexes.
And that's what we're doing
in columns four through six,
is we just look at the inverse of that
as a measure of proximity.
In panel B and panel C, we
do other things to account
for the fact that there are
lots of zeros in our data.
So in panel B we limit our
analysis of use a Tobit analysis,
which allows us to account for the fact
that we're truncated at zero,
we get very similar results.
So the closer you are to the
camp, and the more refugees
there are, the higher the
nighttime lights indexes.
And then in panel C, we just
use a linear probability model,
which is a zero one for do
you have any nighttime lights
index at all?
And again, very robust results.
What is I like to show
instead of that messy table
is this beautiful picture
which basically tells the story
in a picture.
So first in panel A, what we're
looking at, is we take bins
of 10 kilometers away
from the camp, and we look
at the average of the
nighttime lights in that bin
as the refugee population increases.
And you can see really this
effect is coming from villages
that are within 10 kilometers of the camp.
So a 10% increase in the
refugee population is associated
with 3.7% increase in the luminosity index
or a proxy of economic activity.
When we look at these
counterfactual and placebo towns,
so in panel B we say, "Okay,
let's just assume that the camp
was located in Lokichar, and
let's see what the effect
of the increasing refugee population is."
Well, there's no effect,
and that's what we would expect, right?
And then in panel C,
what we're looking at is
this placebo of Lokichogio,
which is the place where
originally all the NGO activity
was occurring.
And what's fascinating
about this is, first of all,
you don't see any effect
close to Lokichogio,
but when we look at the
distance bin that's associated
with Kakuma, you see
the effect for Kakuma.
So this for us was very
reassuring, to say,
"Look, there's something going on."
So as more refugees come into the camp,
economic activity is increasing over time.
What we then do is we take
our cross-sectional data
and we just look at
consumption using the HSNP data
at distance bins to Kakuma.
And again, what we find is
that households that are living
within 10 kilometers of the camp,
their consumption is 25% higher
than these other households
that are living farther
away from the camp.
So these two estimates
allow us to essentially do
a back of the envelope
calculation and let us know
what is the elasticity of consumption
with respect to refugee inflows.
And that's about 0.55,
which is pretty high.
So with a 10% increase in
the refugee population.
We look at other mechanisms.
I won't go into the the estimation,
but we look at what are the mechanisms
that are potentially driving this result.
And it appears that there
are two main mechanisms.
The first is that is
through the labor market.
So for households that
live near to the camp,
there's more employment in
low-skilled occupations.
So remember at the time
of the establishment
of the refugee camp, there
essentially was no labor market
for Turkana people.
They were just herding
cattle, essentially.
Now, presently, there
are people who are living
near the camp, working for
UNHCR in low-skilled occupations
as cleaners, as cooks, as
drivers, as greeting officers
when people come into the camp.
The other main channel that we find
is through the livestock market.
And this is pretty intuitive
when you think about it.
So refugees get a food
aid package from the WFP,
the World Food Program,
and that consists of flour, oil, beans,
and rice essentially, but there's no meat.
And most of these cultures eat meat.
And what do the Turkana
have? They have meat.
So there's an exchange
between Turkana producers
who can sell their meat in
the main livestock market
in Kakuma and refugee
households who are able
to buy this meat.
And so what we find is
that the livestock prices
closer to the camp are rising
with the influx of refugees.
And so the takeaways from this first paper
really is that there's
considerable economic links
between the refugee and the
host community in this context.
And at least in this context,
which is one of the
largest camps in the world,
refugee camps do generate
some positive benefits
for the local economy.
And there's obviously caveats.
We look at a particular
camp in a rural area,
this is not representative of all camps,
but I would say
representative of many camps.
But obviously the effects
are gonna be different
in other settings.
I can't say anything about
what are these effects
going to be in the US or
in Europe or in Australia.
Furthermore, our
counterfactual is not perfect.
We did the best that we could
with the data that we had,
but it's not perfect.
So I'm not necessarily
claiming that it's causal,
but it's highly, highly suggestive.
And what we are observing
here are average effects.
So we don't look at any heterogeneity,
we can't do a cost
benefit analysis and say,
"The benefit of hosting refugees
will be this much in GDP."
We can't say that.
But what we can say is
that there's a strong link
between the host and the refugee community
that benefits both.
So what we do in the
second paper is we exploit
this natural experiment that happened
right as we were just getting ready
to collect the data for the first paper.
There was, I don't know if
any of you remember this,
but there was a terrorist attack
on Garissa University College,
which is in the northeast
of Kenya, in April, 2015.
An Al Shabaab claimed
responsibility for that attack
where over a hundred people died
and many people were injured.
The Kenyan government
was obviously distressed,
and as a result expressed
concern about the lack
of oversight of money-sending agencies,
specifically what they were
calling Muslim transfers
through a transfer system known as hawala.
So I'll get into the details
of hawala in a minute,
but it's essentially a
money exchange rooted
in Islamic finance, and
mostly limited people
who are using hawala are mostly Muslim.
So the Kenyan government
says, "All right, nope,
we're shutting down hawala
because this is funding
terrorist activities.
And so the central bank shut
down all hawala transfers,
starting on April 8th, 2015,
and reopened them again in June of 2015.
So we were already collecting our data,
we started to collect
our data in early June.
So we're able to... We asked
households, retrospectively,
"What was your consumption before April?"
And then, "What is your consumption now?"
And we're able to try and
understand how this shock
to remittances may have affected
not only refugee households,
but Turkana households as well.
So how does hawala work?
Hawala is an informal
way of transferring money
between two people.
So essentially, you're
person A and you say,
"I wanna send money to person B,
and I'm gonna do that by
going to my hawala dealer,
person X."
And you say, "Okay, I wanna
send my friend some money."
And the dealer says, "Okay, great.
How much do you wanna send them?
And what is the password
that they need to give
to pick up the money?"
So you give them that information.
The hawala dealer then
goes to their friend,
hawala dealer M, who's nearby
to your friend and says,
"Okay, they're sending the
money. Here's the money."
They don't actually exchange.
So the dealers don't
necessarily exchange money
directly right away.
This is an informal transfer system
based on the honor system.
So at some point, these people,
these dealers will settle up,
but there isn't necessarily
an actual exchange of money
at the time.
So it's really based on
the honor system and trust,
and there's no interest, there's no fees.
The fees are very low because it follows
Islamic financial principles.
So then the dealer
says, "All right, great.
I have the information."
Your friend comes in to pick up the money,
they give the password,
they get the money.
And that's how hawala works.
In spite of its informalness,
there are formal businesses.
So this is a picture of Dahabshiil,
which is the largest hawala
dealer in Kenya, certainly.
So it is formalized institutionally,
but it's really based on the honor system,
and the fees are really low.
So the government of Kenya says,
"All right, no hawala transfers."
However, things like Western Union
and other forms of mobile money transfers
were still able to
function over this time.
So when we think about how this shutdown
could impact first refugees.
Obviously there would be
direct negative effects
on households who are
previously using remittances,
but there could be positive externalities
or positive spillover
effects on other households
if the decrease in purchasing
from the households
who are affected lower prices.
So if you have a decrease in
demand from the households
who can no longer buy
what they were buying,
this will push prices down.
And if you weren't affected,
this is positive for you
because you can buy things for cheaper.
But if you're a household
that is selling those goods,
you will be hurt by those lower prices.
So again, the effects
are kind of ambiguous
or at least heterogeneous.
And so we'll try to exploit,
we'll try to look at this
heterogeneity in our analysis.
When you think about Turkana
households or host households,
there will be just like producers,
refugee producers or refugee
sellers, good sellers,
there would be negative
effects on households
who are selling items to
refugees, if the demand
for those items falls as a result
of their reduction in income.
But again, if you're a household
who's consuming these goods
that have the price lowered,
then you benefit from having
a lower price of consumption.
Or there could just be
no effect on households
if you're uninvolved in markets at all.
And some Turkana households
are not involved in markets,
although, as we established
in the first paper,
the ones that live around
the camp certainly are
involved in markets.
So to look at this, we
interviewed hawaladeers.
So there are hawala
dealers inside of the camp
that we were able to interview
and get some qualitative information from.
And then we also have
the two household surveys
that we were conducting right
at the time of the shutdown.
So we have the refugee household survey,
which we conducted from
June 9th to the 20th,
so that the ban was lifted on the 22nd.
So all of the refugees in
our household we interviewed
while they were currently
unable to access hawala.
The Turkana household,
roughly the same time,
we have a few households
that we interviewed
after the ban was lifted.
But we asked a lot of different
information in the household
on their demographics,
on their employment.
We had a consumption schedule.
So that's largely what
we'll use to understand
what are the impacts.
And we asked households, "What
was your consumption like
in the first week of April
versus at the time of the survey?"
So obviously a caveat is
that the pre-data we have
is retrospective, but
nonetheless, we do our best.
So when we interviewed
these hawala dealers,
they tell us that the remittance
shutdown was complete.
It wasn't forced. They could
not make any transfers.
When we talked to them about
what their transfers were like
prior to the shutdown, they were enormous.
So the average monthly
transfers for Dahabshiil
was about $60,000 USD.
When we look across these
five dealers in the camp,
what they report suggests
that there's 2.4 million USD
in transfers occurring annually.
This is enormous.
And there are other researchers
who prior to the shutdown,
have been doing work
on hawala in the camp,
and this data is completely consistent
with what they have collected as well.
So, I mean, this is an enormous
amount of economic activity
that's occurring.
And that was stopped
for a couple of months.
When we interviewed refugees,
what we found is that 60%
of refugees had received
remittances in the past year.
The average size of the last
transfer was about $200,
and they receive around
six transfers per year.
So again, this is a lot
of economic activity
coming into the camp.
When you compare that to
the GDP per capita in Kenya,
which was around $1,500 USD
in 2016, this is significant.
54% of remittances occur through hawala.
This is largely due to the
fact that there's a huge
Somali population in
the camp who are Muslim,
and there are other smaller
populations as well.
But this is also, as a researcher,
this was nice for us,
because we have variations.
So not everyone is receiving hawala,
some people are receiving
hawala and we can exploit
that heterogeneity to
really try and understand
the various channels.
45% of the remittance
receivers who we interviewed,
they reported that they
experienced a decrease
in remittances since the shutdown.
So when we just look before and after,
we just compare everyone
in our refugee sample.
So 170 households, we compare
their consumption in April
to their consumption in
June with a simple T test,
we don't find any differences.
So there was no change on
average, but as I mentioned,
there's significant
heterogeneity in this population.
And so if the first level
of heterogeneity we look at
is just, "Do you receive transfers
or do you not receive transfers?"
And you can see... Regardless
of whether it's hawala.
So you can see that
people whose languages...
We didn't ask people,
"What is your religion?"
But we know the language
that the interview
was conducted in, and people
from Somalia, Nuba, and Darfur
are mostly Muslim.
And so we use that as our
proxy sort of for how exposed
to hawala would you be.
And so people who we think
would be largely most likely
to use hawala and who had
received transfers previously,
there's a big difference
in their consumption before and after.
And people who've been in the camp longer
were more affected, had
a lower consumption.
I'm sorry, their transfers were affected.
But they actually, the people...
Yeah, their transfers
were affected, sorry.
And people who have household
enterprises were affected.
So these are the business
owners who are probably using
remittances to fund their businesses.
And again, people whose
income was largely...
Larger share of their income
was coming from businesses,
as opposed to being employed
or to selling animals,
they also were affected by the shutdown.
Again, these are just
simple comparisons of needs.
So then we look again at
those who used hawala,
specifically, and it's a
similar pattern, right?
So people who are more likely
to use hawala were impacted.
People who said their transfers...
People who use hawala
were more likely to say
that their transfers had
decreased since April,
they are less likely
to be selling animals.
So this is consistent
with what we would think
of the characteristics of
people who would be impacted
by the shutdown.
Then we try to estimate
the effect of this shutdown
on consumption for users compared
to non-users before and after the shock.
So this is empirically something
similar to what we'd call
a difference in differences.
The only caveat is that we
don't have a whole panel
of pre-data.
We're really just looking
at these two periods,
one of which was a retrospective survey,
but nonetheless could be informative.
So what we look at is your
consumption in April and in June,
and we regress that on a dummy for whether
this was the June period
that you reported.
And then we interact that
with sources of heterogeneity.
So did you use hawala in the past?
Were you interviewed in a language
that is associated with Islam?
Did you or do you earn wages primarily?
Do you own a business?
And then we, sorry, we include
a household-fixed effect
to control for unobservable
factors about the household
that don't change over time.
And what do we find?
So the first thing we find
is that for households
who received hawala in the past,
when we look at their consumption in June
compared to their consumption in April,
what we find is there's a
decrease in some pretty key goods,
which include milk and meat,
which also happen to come
from things like cows and goats and sheep
that they're not producing,
the Turkana households are producing.
So already we sort of
anticipate this might have
a spillover effect onto
the local community.
And this decrease in
consumption is pretty large.
So it's a 26 to 33%
decrease in the consumption
of these goods per
households that use hawala.
When we look at households
who don't receive hawala,
that's what this coefficient captures is,
is that there's actually an
increase in the consumption
of these, and these would
be considered luxury goods.
So things like sugar, milk, and meat,
they don't come in the aid package.
They're not things that
people eat every day normally,
They are more expensive.
And so when you look at households
who didn't receive hawala
and you look at their consumption in June
compared to their consumption in April,
we see an increase in the
consumption of these luxury goods.
So this suggests there
must have been some kind
of price impact on these goods,
if you can increase your
consumption of them,
that they're probably cheaper.
And that would be driven by the fact
that the hawala households
have reduced their demand
for these goods.
We run the same estimation just looking
at a different measure of hawala exposure.
So instead of the direct
question, "Do you use hawala?"
we just look at what language
was the interview conducted in,
and we find a very similar effect here.
So households that speak
Somali, Nuba, or Darfuri
have reduced their consumption
of milk and meat in June
compared to April.
And we do still see, at
least a positive increase
for sugar in these other households.
Then we look at more heterogeneous impacts
by the income source.
So were you a wage worker?
Did you own your own business?
And again, we still use
the interaction of hawala.
So again, we still see this
reduction in consumption
for hawala households, but
we don't really see an impact
on wage workers or people
who own businesses, so...
Then we look at the Turkana households.
So we have reason to
believe there could be,
especially with the
reduction of meat and milk,
there could be spillover effects
onto the Turkana households,
particularly if they're
producing these things,
if they're selling these
goods to the refugees.
And so we leverage, again,
our empirical strategy.
We're looking at households
that are close to the camp
and far away from the camp
using those counterfactual towns
I had told you about before.
And we're looking at their
change in consumption
between April and June,
depending on whether they
live in the Kakuma sample
or if they are farther
outside of the Kakuma sample.
And then we also look
at their heterogeneity
by their income source.
Are they producing livestock
or are they doing other things?
Are they more exposed
to this shock or not?
And what we find is
that, in terms of things
that we think would
confound this analysis,
their income and assets between households
who live in Kakuma versus
don't live in Kakuma
are basically the same.
So in terms of wealth, on average,
these households are the same.
So we would be concerned,
right, if for example,
households living near Kakuma
were just poorer on average.
That would suggest that
if we did find any effect,
it's just because these
households are poor,
we don't have reason to
believe that would be poorer.
In fact, we think they would be richer
because they're so
linked into this economy.
But on average we find that
they're basically the same.
But what we do find is if
we look at their consumption
in June, it's much
lower for the households
that are living near Kakuma.
And we do find that they've
reported they've decreased
their food consumption.
They're more likely to have
decreased their food consumption
over time between April and June.
So then we estimate more
formally this impact.
And what we just look at
a simple regression is,
"What was the change in your
purchase of sugar and tea
and milk, these more luxury goods?"
If you're in the Kakuma sample,
your consumption decreased
for sugar and tea.
This is just if you purchased
it on the intensive margin,
it doesn't seem like there's any effect.
But whether external margin,
did you purchase or did you not purchase?
You're much less likely that
to purchase these things
if you're living in Kakuma.
And then we look at the
heterogeneity by how exposed
to this shock would you be.
Well, if you're selling animals,
you're gonna be more exposed to this shock
because we already
demonstrated that the demand
for these goods decreased.
And in fact, we find that
this is really driven
by households who are selling animals.
And the probability of
consumption has decreased
by 12 and 15% for sugar
and tea, respectively.
So what we find here is that, on average,
refugees are not hurt by the shutdown.
But the more exposed
you were to this shock,
not surprisingly, the bigger the effect.
So hawala-receiving refugees,
they reduced their
consumption of key goods
as a result of this shock,
from 23 to 29%, including meat,
which they buy from
the Turkana households.
Other groups were not as
affected by this shock.
And if anything, non-hawala households
were positively affected by this shock
through the reduction
in price of these goods.
We find spillover effects
to Turkana households,
particularly those who are
producing meat and milk
and these goods that hawala households
reduce their consumption of.
And so that results in a
reduction of the purchase
of key luxury goods, sugar and tea,
by the Turkana households.
And so I think the main
takeaway from this paper
is that things like blunt policies,
like blockages to remittances,
they can have a really negative effect,
especially on the populations
they weren't intended
to impact.
And so we need to be thoughtful
about how we approach
these kinds of policies.
So that's all I have for you today.
I'm a little bit early,
but I hope that we can have
a nice discussion.
This is just a picture that
I took of a Turkana household
outside of Kakuma, and
it's pretty representative
of their way of life.
And yeah, so I hope that
you learned something,
and I look forward to our discussion.
- Great. Thank you so much, Sarah,
for this really engaging presentation.
So for those of you in the audience,
please feel free to use
the raised hand feature
if you have any specific
questions, or use the chat.
I'll exercise my privilege
of going first to ask.
So especially given that this is kind of
a more established project
and one that you're sort of,
have kind of closed the book on,
I wanted to ask you, in particular
for some of the students
in the audience, to reflect a
little bit on the experience
of doing this research project.
So a few things that
are obviously striking,
this is a very challenging
area to do research in
for a number of reasons.
So if you could talk a
little about your field work
and some of that.
One thing that's really
striking and really lovely,
I think, about the research
and the presentation is,
you're very forthcoming about
some of the shortcomings,
but you do a lot of
creative things, I think,
to get some empirical leverage
in places that I think
would be really hard to get like that
perfect identification strategy.
So I'd also love to hear a little bit
about your thought process,
how you kind of developed those things.
- Yeah, thanks. Thanks for that, Emily.
Yeah, first I'll speak
about the fieldwork.
So I mean, I've done a lot
of fieldwork in my life,
and this certainly was
not the first fieldwork
that I had ever done.
But to this day, remains the
most challenging fieldwork
I've ever done.
I mean, first of all, just the condition,
the environmental
conditions are very tough.
So we were there in May,
June, July, and August,
which are some of the hottest months.
It's very arid, it's very dusty.
It was just physically very...
And I wasn't even conducting interviews,
I was just managing a
field team and going out
for a couple hours to check
on people and then debriefing
at the lovely Ethiopian restaurant.
And that in itself was
the most challenging work
I've ever done, environmentally, but also
it's a difficult region
politically in terms of security.
So at the time we had to
travel with armed guards
everywhere we went.
So, I guess I should take an
even bigger step back and say,
this work would not have
been possible if it were not
for the support of the
World Bank and UNHCR.
So essentially the way we came into...
We didn't just rock up
to the camp and say,
"Hey, we wanna do some interviews."
This kind of work requires a
lot of institutional support.
So we were invited by the
World Bank and the UNHCR
to conduct this study.
And the first paper
resulted in a policy paper
that the World Bank has
published and it informed policy
in Kenya about what they were
going to do with the camps.
So to do this kind of fieldwork,
and speaking to the students in the room,
to do this kind of fieldwork requires
a very strong institutional
partner and support,
because otherwise it's not possible,
but it's also not appropriate, right?
So I think there was a lot
of conversation between UNHCR
and the World Bank and
local Turkana leaders.
So the very first thing
that we did when we arrived
in Turkana, even though we
had the support of UNHCR
and the World Bank, we
went to each of these
counterfactual towns and we
met with the political leaders
of those towns, introduced
ourselves and said,
"Here's what we're doing.
Here's who we're working with.
Do we have your support to
work in your community?"
And those were long conversations,
and is the first step
you have to do when you conduct
this kind of field work.
And thankfully we got the
support, but yeah, I mean,
it was intense, it was intense.
And anytime we traveled
to these other towns,
we really were accompanied by armed guards,
and I had never experiencing
anything like that prior,
and I haven't since.
So yeah, it was hard.
And then in terms of
the empirical strategy,
I have one foot in the
development economics world,
and I think, as many of you
know, that's the world of RCTs.
(Randomized Control Trials)
And I've certainly done
RCTs and they're appropriate
for certain questions,
but this is very clearly something
that you can't randomize,
and not everything and/or
should be answered with an RCT.
And so I think what we
said to ourselves is like,
"How could we possibly piece
together enough evidence
that would be highly
suggestive of something?"
So that's why we said, "All
right, obviously we can do
things cross-sectionally
and so let's think about,
empirically, what are the types of things
that can confound any kind of analysis,
unobservable or observable."
And that's sort of how we came up
with the counterfactual towns
in our cross-sectional analysis.
And then we said, "Okay, how could we..."
Essentially what we're trying to answer
is a long-term question,
but we only have a snapshot of data.
So how could we possibly
get data that would allow us
to look at these longer
term effects, which,
if you haven't worked with
the nighttime lights data,
I would encourage you to look into it.
It's a really phenomenal set
of data and it allows you
to answer questions even in
very remote parts of the world.
So, yeah, I mean, I think we're
living in a fortunate time
of data where there's
just all of this data
that has become available to us.
And that's both good and bad.
You have to be smart and intentional
with how you use the data.
But I hope that I've
convinced you that we were.
- Yeah. Great.
Are there other questions?
I have a few more, if we....
So if no one else has a question,
I guess one thing I wanted
to in invite Sarah to do
is talk about some of her current work.
I know that's kind of evolved in sort
of an econ history-ish direction,
but also relating to migration
and also relating to,
I think, some of these
really important questions
related to culture, institutions, history
that kind of actually
get raised a little bit,
especially in this sort of
longer term analysis that you do
in this first paper.
So I'd be curious to know
if you see any sort of
through-line with this earlier
work to your current work,
or you think of it as more of a departure?
But it'd be great to hear about
some of your current projects as well.
- Yeah, I mean,
I would love to talk
about my current projects
and I'm super excited about them.
I see them... So to back up
what Emily's referring to
is at the moment I'm
working on a large project
that was funded by the
Australian Research Council
to understand the dynamics
of racial violence
in the United States, going
back to before the Civil War,
all the way up until today.
And obviously migration is a part of that.
I'm not looking directly
at migration at the moment,
but certainly conflict is
at the root of that project.
And I do see these two as being related,
certainly through the
long-term impacts that conflict
can have on a society and
the protracted situations
that it creates.
And so what I'm doing in that
paper is essentially trying
to understand how did
the Civil War contribute
to protracted racial violence
in the United States.
And so we Americans love
to talk about the Civil War
and how it was the bloodiest war
in all of our wars combined.
And it was obviously a pivotal
moment for race relations
in the United States.
It ended the institution of slavery,
and at least in the very
early years following,
during reconstruction, ushered in an era
of progressive civil rights
that were mainly granted
to Black men.
And what I do in the paper
essentially is look at
how did the casualties that
were sustained in the Civil War,
so in the south, only white
men fought in the Confederacy.
And nearly 25% of the
young male population,
white male population, died
fighting in the Civil War.
And that had a significant
demographic effect
on the population.
So not only do you have
a shift in the balance
of racial power.
Now there's relatively more
Black men than white men
who now have political
rights and economic rights
that are for some white
southerners perceived as a threat
to the social order.
But there's also a shift in
gendered power because you have
all these young white men who are dying,
and now there's a what we'd
call engrossed econ speed.
We would say there's a
surplus of white women,
or there's this disruption
to what we would call
the white marriage market.
So there's a generation
of young white women
who are unmarried.
They're either widowed or
they can't find partners
who are their age because
they have died in the war.
And so essentially what I'm
looking at is the intersection
of these two forms of power.
So you have a shift in racial power
and you have a shift in gendered power,
and that creates a perfect
storm of racism and violence.
And what we're finding
in this paper is that,
not only is there an
increase in racial violence
in places where the white
male death rate was higher,
but there's a particular type of violence.
So lynchings were the
main form of violence
used against Black people
for a hundred-plus years.
But in particular in
about 40% of lynchings,
when you look at the data,
the excuse given for the
lynching was that a Black man
had sexually assaulted a white woman.
And we know Ida B. Welles was
working on this in the 1890s.
We know that these are false accusations.
And she has a really
famous quote saying that
if you look at four-fifths
of these accusations,
they would be considered adultery.
And so what she's
insinuating is that actually
these are consensual
relationships that were happening
between white women and Black men.
And because they were
taboo and bucked the norms
of the social order, they
were often called rape.
And someone's father finds
out that his daughter
is having an illicit
relationship and tells her
to claim that she's been raped.
And this justifies the lynchings.
And in fact, "To Kill a
Mockingbird" is all about this.
So this is an enduring
phenomenon in our culture.
And what our work is essentially showing
is that in these places
where more white men died
in the Civil War, you see an
increase in racial violence,
but it's primarily through
this sexual channel.
So you only see more lynchings
using sexual excuses.
You don't see more lynchings
for murder or assault
or arson or theft, it's only
using the sexual excuse.
And then we combine that
with data from the newspapers
that we scraped keywords from newspapers,
which were highly localized at the time.
And what we find is there's
a narrative in the places
where more white deaths
happened in the Civil War.
There's a narrative in the newspapers
that Black men are rapists, essentially.
And we actually don't see
this during reconstruction.
So we have a very long-term set of data,
we're looking from 1850
all the way up until today.
And you don't see this narrative happening
during reconstruction,
when the south was
occupied by federal troops.
But as soon as reconstruction ends
and as soon as the Democrats,
which were not the
progressive party at the time,
are able to run again for office,
you see more support for
the Democratic party.
and you also see the
votes shift Republican
in the late fifties and sixties,
when the parties shifted
their policies toward race.
You see this narrative
being used in the newspapers
that's consistent all
the way up until 1930,
which is where our data ends for that.
And then when you look at the
implicit association test,
which I don't know how
familiar any of you guys are
with this, but it's a test
that Harvard does online.
You should take it.
And it gives you pictures
of Black and white faces
and good and bad words, and
you associate these words
with faces.
We find actually no
effect on implicit bias.
But when you look at the
self-reported questions
that respondents are asked
at the end of the survey,
there is an association
today among respondents
who are living in a place
that had a big shock
during the Civil War and
their racial attitudes.
And they're largely
ones that are consistent
with this narrative.
So they're more likely to think
that Black people are violent.
They're less likely to want
to have a sexual relationship
with a Black person.
They're less likely to want
to have a Black roommate.
They feel nervous and
uncomfortable around Black people.
So yeah, this is still a work in progress.
And we have a working paper
that's up on my website,
if you'd like to read it.
We're in the process of revising it.
But yeah, it's an obvious tragic finding,
but I think it's an important
one for us to share,
and we're excited to
be able to share that.
- Absolutely. I'll
definitely check it out.
And I think, strangely, kind
of there is a connection
with this sort of legacies of conflict,
legacies of violence literature.
- Yeah.
- Yes. Any other questions on that case?
Let me thank again, Sarah, especially,
for being so flexible at the time,
so we can all make it.
A large number of students I
know are also gonna watch this
on recording, so I'd also like
to thank you for additionally
to this great presentation
to being so candid
about sort of the experience
of working in this topic.
I think to me is really
extraordinarily valuable
for people to hear.
And we're looking forward to seeing
how this new research agenda develops.
- Great. Thank you so much, Emily.
And thank you so much to
the center for having me.
This has really been wonderful.
And please, for those
of you who are watching
the recorded version or even watching now,
really feel free to reach out.
I'm always happy to talk about my research
and would love to hear from you.
- [Emily] Thank you very much.
A pleasure to have you here.